- [Host] Thanks to Mack Weldon
for keeping Legal Eagle in the air
and helping me look fly.
What it's like doing a
virtual depo right now.
(host laughs)
If you're in Florida,
this is what you look like
because you're not wearing a shirt.
Because apparently
they're not wearing shirts
in Florida, because
(fan cheers)
Florida.
(calming jazz music)
(raindrops pitter-pattering)
(distant sirens ring)
(window swishes)
(beverage trickles)
(fire crackles)
Oh, I didn't see you there,
and set up a tri-pod and a camera
and a whole bunch of lights.
Well, since you're here,
and we're all locked inside in
this never-ending Chekhov's winter,
this prison of our own homes,
this panopticon of social media
and lockdown orders,
I guess we might as well do a meme review.
Since everyone loves
lawyers and Coronavirus,
might as well combine
everyone's two favorite things together.
Yeah, let's do a
legal-Coronavirus meme review.
(drums beat)
Meme Review!
Meme Review trademark of PewDiePie.
All rights reserved.
(drums beat)
As a criminal lawyer,
what's the biggest issue you're dealing
with in 2020?
Trying to figure out how to correctly run
the vacuum cleaner and the dishwasher.
(host laughs) Oh man,
it's been so interesting seeing
how the legal profession functions
when we're all working
from home these days.
It's been really interesting seeing
that a lot of the stuff
that makes lawyers expensive,
like going into court and waiting there
for hours just to have a minor hearing,
can actually be accomplished
over video conferencing software.
Yeah, trying to work the vacuum cleaner
and the dishwasher while
sometimes appearing
in court can be very difficult.
And apparently in Florida
they are appearing
on video conferences from
home without shirts on.
So all of you lawyers out there,
please put a shirt on.
If you're showing up to court,
put on a tie even if
it's in your own home.
(drums beat)
No, you can't approach the bench
if you have a cold.
Oh, big mistake!
Big mistake.
He approached the judge without asking
for permission first.
You know what happens when you approach
the judge without asking
for permission entering the well,
but this cartoonist screwed that up
because you wouldn't ask for permission
if you were already there.
Think about that.
(drums beat)
If you are experiencing
the following symptoms:
headache, body aches,
shortness of breath, fever,
developed aches and pains,
difficulty sleeping,
easily frustrated,
can't communicate properly,
feeling dizzy, this in
not the Coronavirus,
these are the effects
of being an attorney.
(host laughs)
Oh boy that hits close to home.
It can be tough being a lawyer out there.
And look, I know it's tough
for everyone these days,
but yeah, lawyers deal with this stuff
on a regular basis.
'Cause we work really, really long hours.
We'll work 10, 12 hours a day,
seven days a week often
if we're preparing for trial.
Often people confuse being a jerk
with being a disposition.
No, it's actually just a consequence
of becoming a lawyer.
You become a jerk,
and you get all the aches and pains
that go with it.
So, yeah.
I feel that.
(drums beat)
What it's like doing a
virtual depo right now.
(host laughs)
Uh yeah.
As you may know if you watch this channel,
a deposition is questioning
a witness under oath,
and you'll have a
stenographer there taking
down the words that are being spoken.
Well you can't do that now because you're
within six feet,
you're within the same room.
You don't want to spread the germs.
So, what lawyers have taken
to doing is doing a virtual depo.
You are having a video conference,
and the witness is still under oath.
You have the stenographer call in
to the virtual depo,
and maybe they're recording it
for future posterity,
which is something they should do anyway,
and it drives me insane
that they don't record
these things often.
It should be recorded.
You should be able to refer back to it
without having to refer to the transcript
from the stenographer.
But anyway, if you're in Florida,
this is what you look like
because you're not wearing a shirt.
Because apparently
they're not wearing shirts
in Florida because
(fan cheers)
Florida.
(drums beat)
Divorce lawyers in April
after two-week Coronavirus quarantine.
(host laughs)
You know consider yourself lucky
if you have a significant other
to spend the quarantine with,
and you come out stronger at the end
of the quarantine.
(drums beat)
Government orders non-essential workers
to work from home.
Lawyers somehow are essential workers.
Well look,
especially you have to
imagine district attorneys
and public defenders,
certainly essential workers,
and as I mentioned in another video,
the prisons are being hit really,
really hard by Coronavirus,
because you can imagine everyone is forced
to be in confinement,
and we're hearing numbers of like 80,
90 and 100% infection
rates in some prisons.
It's a really, really
bad time for lawyers,
for prison guards, for judges,
for district attorneys, public defenders.
It's not really a laughing matter.
I mean, I feel it's tough for everyone.
But you know,
life has to go on.
The wheels of the judicial
system have to go on.
(drums beat)
COVID-19 turning lawyers into cavemen.
Last day before--
Oh poor Matthew Perry.
Remember Matthew Perry?
He was a good-looking guy.
Yeah, I am trying to workout,
but I think I'm gonna be leaving lockdown
with a few extra Coronavirus pounds.
It's just hard not leaving the house,
going on maybe one walk.
I think I went outside a couple days ago.
That was good time.
I feel like we're all
at home doing nothing
but sitting around and drinking Mr. Pibb
and Red Vines and talking
about friends alum Matthew Perry.
(drums beat)
You know this would be
more fun with a friend.
I got an idea.
Hey, are you doing anything right now?
Yeah somebody set up a tripod
and a camera in my family room.
You wanna react to some legal memes?
Cool. I'll send you the Zoom link.
Okay, is this working?
- Hello.
- Uh you're frozen.
Yeah why don't you try and log in again?
Yeah, no, try it again.
No, I can't hear you.
Can you hear me?
(bell dings)
All right.
(drums beat)
- All right, day seven of quarantine,
attorneys let's argue,
I wanna feel something.
Oh man, I really feel that.
Do you feel that?
- I feel this deep.
I feel this deep for two reasons.
Firstly, my housemates are lawyers,
and so we get our
arguing to another level.
There is no playing around when it comes
to who hasn't done the dishes
'cause we are ready to moot.
- Do people ever talk to you and say,
I'm really good at arguing,
therefore I should go to law school?
- People don't say it to me,
because I don't think I am.
In real life I think I am
the most non-confrontational person,
so I actually don't argue a lot.
But you know when you kind of been in,
not an argument,
but when you've kind of
fallen out with a friend.
And then you stand in the
shower later listening
to emotional Adele music,
and you think of all the
things you could've said
in that moment.
Maybe this is not relatable
with the Adele point,
but kind of like when you come away
from an argument or a confrontation,
and you think of all the arguments
you could've made,
and that's when I knew
I'd be a good lawyer
'cause I was like,
you see, lawyers don't have
to be super confrontational in person
'cause they can do all
their preparation beforehand
and turn up with all of their arguments
in their pristine, golden, shiny form.
(drums beat)
Family, religion, friendship,
these are the three demons you must slay
if you want to succeed in big law.
(Eve laughs)
- Oh no!
It's true.
- Yeah, it's true.
I agree.
- How would you say your life has changed
under the Damocles of the Coronavirus
and being forced to lockdown?
Are you less social or more social
than working normal hours at the firm?
- That is a really hard one
because I train with a lot
of other trainee lawyers my own age,
and we often go out for coffee together.
And we eat lunch together.
And I really like that.
And now I'm so stir-crazy 'cause
I don't have someone
to just break out and talk to.
So I'm probably more anti-social.
(host laughs)
But I'm definitely outside
a lot more,
which sounds kind of depressing.
But I often think it's very easy
when you work at a law firm
that you will just be inside all day.
Unless you make the active effort
to go and get coffee or
go and eat lunch out,
you won't leave.
You won't leave.
So now I'm taking as many
walks as I can a day.
(drums beat)
- I was speaking of billable hours.
(host laughs)
(Eve laughs)
- This one I found--
I think this is really funny.
It's just like how the level
of desperation gets more and more
as we're getting further into the crisis.
- Yeah, and I guess some background here,
in big firms lawyers get a salary.
But in order to get that salary,
which is generally pretty good
for people that are just coming out
of law school or college,
you have to work an
insane amount of hours,
and those are called billable hours.
At least in the U.S.,
the very bottom floor would be probably
about 2,000 billable hours.
And if you're a first- or second-year,
it's probably more like
2,300 billable hours.
And that's just hours that you can bill
to a client.
It's not the actual hours
that you work in the firm,
which is often 50% more than that.
So you might be working
3,000 or 3,500 hours
to get 2,000 or 2,300 billable hours.
- I also think it's really interesting,
and I didn't realize
this before I started,
how closely you have to record that time.
- Oh yeah, right!
- My time sheets are so detailed,
and I had no idea that that happened.
Also to give context,
every single task I do per day,
I have to record by the minute
because then when the firm wants
to charge a client,
they then have to turn around and say,
this is exactly what we spent time on.
So you know exactly what
you're gonna pay for.
But that means that every hour--
When I first started I
found it really stressful
because I was kind of like,
do I stop my timers if I go to the toilet?
It was really intense.
- Yeah, well it depends
on if you're thinking
about the client in the bathroom or not.
- Which I wasn't.
I did stop my timers.
(drums beat)
(host laughs)
(Eve laughs)
- Keeping up with the
billable requirement here.
Yeah, the bonus in terms
of toilet paper.
- Of toilet paper.
- I feel like that's an American thing.
Were there shortages of toilet paper
in Great Britain?
- Oh my God.
You have no idea.
People went so crazy.
We had it here as well,
and the funniest thing is I'd walk past
a supermarket,
the same supermarket
every day to the firm.
And every morning there would be lines
of people holding their toilet paper,
and it would be sold out
by 10 minutes past opening.
I was like, it will get back in stock.
It did not get back in stock U.K.-wide
about five weeks.
I was like, oh my God.
What if I actually run out?
So unnecessary.
- Yeah, and I don't see why
the Coronavirus would make people use
more toilet paper.
I guess maybe this is TMI,
but I've been on team
bidet for a long time,
so it doesn't really affect me
as much as everybody else.
- And also I love
how extreme people were getting.
They were like,
obviously BuzzFeed and companies like
that were jumping on the bandwagon,
and like here's how you
can make toilet paper
out of organic leaves.
I'm like, I don't wanna ever--
I don't want it to get to that level.
Can we just not stockpile?
That's an easy solution.
- Yeah, oh my God.
Let's not spend too much time
(Eve laughs)
- On the toilet paper
and move on to the next one here.
(drums beat)
- Receiving deliveries
during the pandemic,
like leave it on the doorstep
and get the hell out of here.
(host laughs)
- I relate to this so hard.
But you know what,
I actually think it's
the other way around.
Someone delivered a parcel yesterday,
and I opened the door,
and the man he had only just put it down.
And he looked up at me,
and he ran backwards,
almost fell over his feet.
And then he was like,
oh I need to take a photo to prove
it's been delivered.
So I stood by my parcel,
and I was like,
I feel now obliged now to pose.
So I stood there with my parcel,
like thank you.
He was like, I only needed a picture
of the parcel.
I didn't need a picture of you.
(man laughs)
- So now there's
this weird photo of me and a parcel
on a database somewhere, like hi.
- I think that means you're spending
too much time on Instagram.
I think you need to step back
from the influencer
lifestyle just a little bit.
- Yeah, I know.
Someone gets out a camera,
and I'm immediately like, yes!
Switched on.
- Skinny arm out in front
and posing with the parcel.
- Yeah, catch my jaw.
- Yeah, I am thanking
my delivery people like
they are soldiers returning from war.
They are really making our lives
I think livable at this point,
so I'm thankful for--
- Yeah they are incredible.
Yeah.
(drums beat)
- I don't own anything.
Prosecuting attorney,
will the witness lower his--
(host laughs)
(Eve laughs)
- Is Joe Exotic a thing in the U.K.?
Is Tiger King making rounds around there?
- So much a thing to the extent
which three nights ago I was like,
maybe I want a mullet.
And then I was like,
no I don't.
No I really don't.
- You may not have a choice.
We're all cutting our own hair these days,
so you may end up with one no matter what.
- Yeah, I might slip and then just have
to become my inner Joe Exotic.
All though maybe I'm
more of a Carole Baskin.
I've not decided yet.
(host laughs)
Maybe I'm one of the tigers.
Who knows?
- Yeah are you team Joe or team Carole?
- Oh definitely team Carole because--
and I love how people were kind of like,
people were kind of like Carole is so,
on Twitter people were like,
Carole is so crazy.
She potentially murdered her ex-husband
and all this sort of thing.
And I'm like,
yeah but he literally keeps 200 tigers
in his land estate in
the middle of America.
How are we normalizing that already?
- Well I mean, yeah.
- He's not the normal one
in this situation.
- Technically Carole
had lions and tigers as well.
But between the two of them,
one of them is spending two decades
in federal prison,
and the other is a free person.
So, I'm not sure who we should be giving
the benefit of the doubt to here.
- This is true,
and I actually think about the guy.
I would love to meet him.
(host laughs)
Also imagine being his lawyer.
I just think that would
be so, so incredible.
(drums beat)
All right, working in the office.
Working from home.
Oh, no!
- This speaks
to me on a deep level.
I won't lie.
(host laughs)
- So at the moment,
all of our internal meetings
at the firm are done by camera.
Everyone's on camera,
like us on this Zoom.
- Yes.
- And so, you kind of feel obliged
to look somewhat not asleep,
but then equally you're like,
but I'm in my own home.
It's a very--
at the start some people were,
everyone was still wearing business wear
at the start.
I was like,
I'm in my own home.
I'm not putting on a suit.
I don't know what's happening.
It's regressed and
regressed and regressed.
Now I'm just turning
up in my t-shirt like,
take me or leave me.
Have me for who I am.
- Yeah, in Florida apparently
they are having trouble
with the attorneys who are showing up
on the Zoom calls without shirts on.
And sometimes you can get away
with wearing less formal stuff below,
but I've never heard--
Well it makes total sense in Florida
that they would show up
in front of the judge
on a video conference call
with opposing counsel.
- Oh my gosh.
In front of a judge?
- No shirt. No shirt.
- Okay so here's the difference.
I know in the U.K. that we have now opened
up virtual courts as well,
and I'm 100% sure if I was in any kind
of judicial situation like that I would be
in full, black business wear.
(drums beat)
- Graduating law school
like I am never going
to financially recover from this.
Oh no!
I had so much law school debt.
Please tell me that you incurred
a whole bunch of debt as well.
- Okay so, I did,
financial and emotional debt,
(host laughs)
but I will say I'm pretty
sure law school fees
in America are way higher than the U.K.
So I kind of don't want
to complain too much
because I'm still in debt,
don't get me wrong,
but I don't think it's near the level
of the States.
- More or less than the
equivalent of $200,000?
Like more or less than 150,000 pounds?
(Eve gasps)
- Damn it.
- I'm at under 25% of that.
(host sighs)
- For four years, I probably owed
around 30 to 40 thousand pounds.
- And you're not even gonna be
a real lawyer doing litigation
at the end of that.
I feel so bad for you.
- We're gonna fall out.
And I'm ready.
I am ready for us to fall out.
That would be the ultimate head-to-head.
We're gonna come back for round two,
and I'm gonna have arguments
as to why transactional lawyers are better
than litigious lawyers.
(drums beat)
- Where can the people
find you on the Internet?
- You can come along with me
on my YouTube channel.
You can also find me on Instagram
and Twitter under the
same handles, evecornwell.
Why did that feel like an interview?
I'm like--
(Eve laughs)
- Well thank you, Eve, so much,
and thank you for providing
some human contact
in these really terrible times.
- Thank you so much for having me.
- [Host] Bye, bye.
- Bye!
- That was fun.
Interacting with people was fun.
I miss that.
(host sighs)
Oh well, more memes.
(drums beat)
Stop spreading stupid
rumors about martial law.
Completely false, we
will continue closing.
This is not martial law.
This fall on NBC, Marshall Law.
(host laughs)
So this is a pet peeve of mine.
It's martial law spelled M-A-R-T-I-A-L,
as in an army, a martial army.
Not Marshall, like Marshall Mathers.
Though I would totally watch that show,
Marshall Law, and then
you have a crossover
with Ice-T from Law & Order,
now that that's been canceled.
♪ Hi, my name is ♪
- [Announcer] Justice.
I mean NBC, make this show.
Make Marshall Law.
That would be amazing.
(drums beat)
Motion to cancel the rest of the year.
Motion granted.
Move to strike the previous portion
of this year too.
Man, screw this year.
(drums beat)
Dear counsel,
by opening up this email you have agreed
to accept electronic service
and stipulated that our motion
for summary judgment will be unopposed.
Stay safe.
(host laughs)
So this is another thing
that lawyers have to deal with.
Except under these
extenuating circumstances,
you have to physically
mail almost everything
or personally deliver motions,
or discovery requests,
and you have to physically file the stuff
with the court.
I've never understood,
except for sort of traditional reasons,
why this is.
Now that everyone can't
really go to court,
although some people still have
to physically file stuff with the court,
we should be able to do
what's called provide things
via electronic service
and accept service electronically.
In this day and age,
it's so much better,
and it's so much more certain
that if you send it via email
or if you have a read
receipt with an email,
that's way better than personally handing
this stuff with a process server
or sending it through the mail.
Although you get crazy stuff like this
where you say,
if you open the email you agree
to accept service and grant my motion
for summary judgment.
It's clever.
That part will not work,
but the other stuff should work.
And we should just do away
with having non-electronic service.
It's nonsense.
(drums beat)
Quarantine pro tip,
if you run out of toilet paper,
that copy of the motion
to compel you received
from opposing counsel will suffice.
(host laughs)
That is true because when
opposing counsel gives
you a motion to compel,
it's garbage,
and it should go in the toilet paper.
If I send a motion to compel,
meritorious and cannot
be used for toilet paper.
(drums beat)
Sadly my side hustle is just billing
more hours.
(host laughs)
Yeah, it's been a while since I've been
in the big firm world.
I was in there for a decade,
and yeah, when you're
in the big firm world
you're side hustle is just more
of your main hustle.
So, I'm glad that I don't have
to do that anymore,
and now I have my own practice.
(drums beat)
(host laughs)
How did that get there?
I know people always speculate
that I'm not actually wearing pants,
but I do actually wear pants
when I record these videos.
Like the pants that I'm
wearing right now are
from Mack Weldon.
They are Mack Weldon's radius pants.
They're increbibally comfortable,
and they're the perfect pants for
this post-apocalyptic,
COVID-19, stay-at-home situation
because they look like real pants,
but they're actually athleisure pants
that are incredibly comfortable.
You can do anything any them.
Because if you have to be stuck at home,
you should wear your Mack Weldon.
Mach Weldon, for the man that wants
to look like they're wearing pants
but doesn't have to.
And these pants are even more comfortable
because I'm pairing them
with Mack Weldon's famous boxer briefs,
which are so comfortable.
But obviously I can't show you that.
Well, hold on.
(host grunts)
Highly recommended.
Because if you're watching this channel,
you're probably an adult,
and you deserve to have
some nice underwear.
Mack Weldon is a mens'
essential clothing company
that focuses on smart design
and premium fabrics to make some
of the most comfortable
clothing out there.
I've ordered Mack Weldon
with my own money for years,
and it's especially great in these times
when I can go online,
and I can order Mack Weldon straight
from their website.
Order as many options and sizes as I want,
have them delivered,
and then return anything that doesn't fit
or I don't like free of charge.
And, if you wanna try out their underwear,
you don't have to even return it
because nobody wants
to use used underwear.
(gavel knocks)
(dog barks)
So if you would like to try Mack Weldon,
get 20% off,
all you have to do is go
to MackWeldon.com/legaleagle
or use the promo code
legaleagle at checkout.
I'll also drop a link in
the doobly-doo as well.
Clicking on the link really helps out
this channel,
and what's great is Mack Weldon has
a loyalty program where if you sign up,
you can get 20% off indefinitely
for all of your future orders
and get access to new
stuff when it comes out.
So, do you agree with my analysis?
Do you disagree with Eve's analysis?
Leave your objections in the comments,
and check out this playlist over here
with all of my other meme reviews
and reactions to the
crazy things on Reddit
and social media and
crazy posts on Facebook.
Just click on this link,
and I'll see you in court.